[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena o
podcast semanal onde a gente indica
troca ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente
leu ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo de
produto discussão eu sou Artur e aa
semana coruja eu sou a e Olimpíadas
apenas Olimpíadas e depois essa vitória
do Brasil hoje também
Nossa Senhora tchau Espanha [__] você
viu que a mina da Espanha meteu ah
jogamos contra o time que para mim não
joga bola se tomou de quatro pro time
que não joga bola imagina jogasse jog
exato É então assim a gente queria podia
fazer um programa só falando de
olimpíadas hoje acho que é a única coisa
que eu sou capaz de falar inteiramente
Inclusive só que a gente na verdade vai
falar sobre algumas outras coisas também
Vamos fazer um giro de notícias de que
tem bastante coisa rolando e a Nvidia
foi pegando no pulo da pirataria e
ilegalidade é isso mas antes da fta tem
jabar isso aqui não falta né pode ser
Olimpíadas pode ser antes antes de
olimpíadas pode ser Copa do Mundo etc
tem nosso jabazinho sempre medalha de
ouro no jabá medalha de ouro no jabá dia
20 24 de Agosto daqui dois finais de
semana dois é dois três finais de semana
a gente tem a quinta edição do workshop
de pensamento crítico e analítico comigo
e com o Dudu da RD e no dia 14 de
setembro a gente tem a quarta Edição do
curso de ai para PMs na prática comigo
com efren a iira vai tá lá também como
sempre falando dos GPT que ele criou e
enfim ambos cursos online ao vivo e
aquele desconto Maroto exclusivo pro
ouvintes tá no link da descrição boa
agora sim bora lá pra pauta Bora
[Música]
lá bom para começar então o giro de
notícias aqui acho que a notícia das
boas é que a decidiu liberar né o cloud
aqui no Brasil Cláudio Claud Sei lá o
Cláudio é o
Cláudio clud Claudinho o Claudinho tá
disponível agora no Brasil também [__]
até que enfim hein mano [__] quanto
tempo [__] merda Demorou PR [__] para
aprender português Pois é e lógico que a
gente testou né pra gente poder falar um
pouquinho aqui vou dar minhas percepções
aqui
cara eu gostei do onboard antes de você
poder de poder digitar e eu tinha tido
essa mesma impressão quando o GPT o o
GPT foi lançado que tinha todo um
negócio tátil também não sei se você
lembra no aplicativo que ele tipo
escrevendo as parados etc antes de você
começar a usar e o celular tremia e tal
foi bem legal assim a experiência o da
tropic agora antes de você poder digitar
ou fazer qualquer Pergunta lá ele também
vai dar um descrições lá pede para
você tipo L aceit todos os termos pede
para você colocar seu nome que não sei o
qu fala que você quer ser chamado Como
que você quer chamado fala que você po
que ele pode errar e etc então assim eu
gostei da explicação guiada assim sabe
um onboarding literalmente um onboarding
mesmo assim é eu gostei desse do
processo assim eu também gostei Tipo ele
te ele te leva até a experiência de
começar um chat né ele não te jog joga
num numa tela faça seu prompt e é isso
eu nem lembro como era um boss do chat
PT na época é mas eu curti o do Cloud
também achei legal eu eu fiz no
navegador né não fiz no aplicativo mas
essa mesma experienci Zinha Outro ponto
ele é mais caro que o GPT E
aí
descob que o a estava pagando mais caro
no GPT aqui ó porque tava pagando em dol
né ultimamente fica a dica que tá exato
fica a dica para quem foi trouxa igual
eu que se você assinar pela App Store
Ele custa R
99,90 e se você assinar pelo site da
Open ai ele custa $2 e ó custa muito
dinheiros a cada mês é isso exatamente
exato Então hoje mesmo vou cancelar
minha assinatura e reass sinar novamente
aqui por outro lugar mas enfim em termos
de preço o cloud tá 110 mais taxas se
você fizer pela web e pelo aplicativo
também é mais barato é R
109,90 esse erro não cometerei mais mas
eu não vou cometer esse de qualquer
forma porque eu não vou assinar dois
dois chats é outras coisas assim eu
tenho uma planilha que eu gerei no GPT
inclusive que eu sempre uso ela tanto
nos cursos e e para testar também
ferramentas e tal Eu testei Basic ente é
uma planilha que pô tem uns números e o
nome do
produto receita que ele vendeu tipo
valor que ele vendeu e coisa do tipo
assim bem simplesinho E aí eu fiz as
mesmas perguntas para ele que é cara que
com essa planilha que D que análise que
a gente pode fazer os resultados
comparando o GPT com o cloud Ele só
trouxe ordens diferentes ele trouxe os
mesmos pontos são 10 pontos aqui ele
trouxe os mesmos só de outras maneiras
só que o cloud trouxe mais contexto para
cada um dos pontos que ele podia que ele
podia analisar sabe eu eu senti um pouco
isso no meu teste eu fiz um teste não
era planejado Mas acabou rolando ali que
eu queria ver queria fazer uma análise
do último quar results da Amazon E aí eu
queria saber especificamente quanto da
receita da Amazon vinha da da parte de
ads né E aí eu baixei o pdf joguei no
Cloud joguei no no chat PT e eu sinto
que a resp os dois me daram a mesma
resposta ali eu sinto que a resposta do
Cláudio ela é mais ela tem um pouco mais
de sustância parece assim ela é Men seca
do que a resposta do chat GPT quando
você faz uma pergunta ali sem prompt
nenhum né Muito uma pergunta muito
direta sim outra coisa também acho que é
uma diferença bem bem bem visível é que
o GPT ele já traz já já trata gráfico
planilha já traz esses formatos nas
respostas né já o cloud Ainda não eh ele
literalmente trouxe textos lá para mim
por mais que tava quebrado em bullets e
tudo mais mas é texto não é ele não tem
um um modelo de geração de imagem né
assim como o chpt tem o Dali e aí eu
acho que muito por isso
pro caso de uso dia a dia ali principal
né se você não tá fazendo algo muito
específico de código que dizem que o
Claudio é muito bom ou um trabalho mais
criativo que também Dizem que o o cloud
3.5 sonet é muito bom eu acho que o chat
ept ainda é o melhor de porque ele te
traz mais funcionalidade no fim por um
preço muito semelhante né quer dizer
descobrimos agora que um preço mais
barato no meu caso que era um preço
muito semelhante mas ele te traz além de
um modelo top de linha né também um
modelo ali de de geração de imagem
ferramenta de de análise de dados e
então acho que ele ainda traz um pouco
mais de coisa do que o cloud traz pro
pro usuário padrão assim sim Eu até
perguntei para ele depois que ele gerou
cara você consegue gerar um gráfico para
mim aí ele falou peço desculpas mas eu
não tenho capacidade de gerar criar ou
manipular imagens diretamente sou um
modelo de linguagem projetado para
processar e gerar texto não para criar
elementos visuais como gráficos ele não
consegue fazer isso via código então só
que aí é isso el no entanto possa
oferecer orientações sobre como você
pode criar esse gráfico usando
ferramentas populares tipo Microsoft
tablô Python e até
R então mas é o chat PT na quando ele
você quando ele gera um gráfico você dá
uma planilha para ele ele gera um
gráfico o que ele tá fazendo é rodando o
código ali por trás né ele tá rodando
não mas ele já te dá ali Prontinho né a
imagem mesmo então o Claud ele não faz
isso de forma alguma o clud ele só traz
as coisas listadas por exemplo ele não
tem processador de código eu fiz uma
pergunta pro dessa planilha que eu
mandei falei cara me ajuda a calcular a
receita total aí por produto ele
literalmente colocou número um produto a
valor valor total número
dois número vezes quantidade igual valor
e já o o GPT ele me traz uma planilha
literalmente já sabe que eu posso
inclusive baixar
ela Então essa é uma das também aí que
que eu vi boa eu não cheguei a testar
essa parte preciso usar mais no fim
preciso preciso dar uma testada a mais
aqui é E aí Acho que outras coisas só
para para resumir aqui cara não não gera
imagens né ainda não dá para mandar
áudio e ter essa conversa e as análises
que tá montando é com texto mesmo né
Assim como eu já já falei aqui boa E aí
aproveitando que você falou de mandar
áudio vamos começar a falar de Open Ai
aqui que uma das novidades aí dessa
semana é que eles começaram a Roll outar
o Advanced Voice mode né que é o aquele
que gerou todo o burburinho no evento
deles ali de conversa muito mais fluida
parecia que você tá conversando com
humano de de fato poder fazer
interrupções e tal Então falaram que vai
começar a chegar para todo mundo que
paga o o chat ept Plus não chegou aqui
para mim acho que não chegou aí para
você você ainda também né Artur Não não
até foi dar uma fuçada extra no dia lá
que eu fiseram ver se parecia mas ainda
não triste mas tô ansioso para usar Vel
tô vendo uns vídeos assim no Twitter e
no YouTube da galera usando eu acho que
para para quem gosta de conversar
sozinho vai ser uma maravilha eu sou
desses malucos Então acho que vai ajudar
a ficar aqui às vezes trocando ideia e e
falando coisas alto para ajudar a chegar
em conclusões acho que vai ser um bom
comp
aqui não sei se você tem essa mania às
vezes eu chamo as pessoas no chat do
trabalho eu falo assim cara pode entrar
aqui no chat rapidinho só para fazer um
sen check só PR eu ver se Tipo o que eu
tô pensando eu não tô completamente
maluco e aí enquanto você fala pra
pessoa você mesmo consegue chegar à
conclusão que você queria total é bom
demais isso eu faço eu fazia isso muito
com o Lucas el participou aqui dos epis
a gente sempre fazer muito vamos
aqui Demis Mas e aí cara só queria ver
se eu não tô maluco boa diga E aí né
Vamos ver aí os próximos quando liberar
aí para para nós a gente traz updates
aqui também só que como sempre toda isso
toda semana acontece né Tem umas
movimentações lá já saiu até o co mesmo
né já sai toda semana tem uma novidade
parece Big Brother essa parada Então
essa semana teve a saída de um dos
co-founders né e que tá indo sabe PR
onde pra concorrência tá ind pai do
Cláudio pro pai do Cláudio tá indo lá
mexer no
Cláudio e o
presidente escutou o podcast aqui e
lembrou do trabalho trabalhe trabalhe
mas não esqueça que as vírgulas
significam
pausas isso que ele falou
S
foras isso E aí ele falou pediu lá pro
Samo e Falou amigão sou o presidente
dessa caramba aqui eu vou tirar um
sabático então também saiu o presidente
da da Open ai é o Greg brockman né exato
falou com s altman fica aí que eu tô
indo ali dar uma descansada é e e só
falar né o cofal que saiu foi o John
schuman que ele liderava o time de pó
Training do chat é então ele tá indo
para
antropic o que ele diz na no twit dele
né que ele quer se envolver mais
Tecnicamente ali né voltar a a fazer um
research mais técnico mas acho que é um
grande move assim um cara que é
cofounder lidera uma das partes super
importantes assim do do produto da
empresa tá indo diretamente para um
concorrente e ele especificamente não e
ele especificamente fal fala né não é ah
não é que ele ele queria trabalhar mais
em ai alignment né que é ele garantiu
Safe guards né da da Inteligência
Artificial E ele fala tip ó não é que a
Open ai não se importa mais com isso que
saiu um monte de gente né que cuidava
mais da parte de de Safety eh mas é
porque eu acho que tem um pessoal legal
na trop acho que vou conseguir voltar a
ter um é uma pegada mais técnica mas
acho que é mais uma pessoa na linha de
que tocava coisas mais voltadas para
alignment Safety e que tá deixando a
empresa No momento ainda que se fala
muito que a Open tem olhado cada vez
menos para isso né é que mais que os
nossos meninos da da Open
aprontaram cara aí eles foram lá e
lançaram o search né anunciaram lá que
vai ter o search
GPT E aí sabe mic nem falou né foi
semana passada e a Microsoft que é uma
das maiores investidoras
lá listou agora o a Open ai como
concorrente então assim será que teremos
teremos ras e fim de relacionamentos Ah
acho pouco provável esse aqui tem mais
cara de ser tipo Ei galera do antitrust
Nós não somos um monopólio eu não li né
mas parece que ontem ou hoje saiu
inclusive uma de Deão super importante
considerando que o Google tem um
monopólio no negócio de search então é
um negócio que tá super em alta no nos
Estados Unidos né e eu acho que parece
um move ali muito de se posicionar como
não estamos criando monopólio não somos
isso daqui então pô é acho tem tem muito
disso hoje em dia é mas assim também
mesmo se eles forem concorrentes n você
v o Google e Apple são concorrentes eles
TM parceria também né então assim eu não
sei se dá para chamar de parceria um
negócio que uma paga bilhões de bilhões
de dinheiros PR outra
ali para ter o seu seu buscador como
principal do produto Mas tudo bem eu
diria que é uma negociação não uma
parceria Ah mas é uma negociação que
enfim poderia ter outros parceiros Ném
poderia ter parceiros exato
enfim e que mais e acho que por último
aqui uma mais nerdice aqui pros
desenvolvedores principalmente mas
também pra gente de produto né hoje no
dia dessa gravação terça-feira a Open ai
anunciou anunciou o structured outputs
nas api do chat GPT que nada mais é do
que você quando tiver fazendo uma
chamada ali para api poder garantir com
certeza que uma estrutura é é Jason que
você passar ali paraa api usar vai ser
respeitada então um dos principais casos
de uso eles até falam isso no no press
lease do gii como um todo é você pegar
dados desestruturados e estruturar eles
de alguma forma né E até então não tinha
uma forma de você garantir isso como
desenvolvedor Então os desenvolvedores
tinham que fazer várias
eh não gambiarras né mas usar vários
ferramentais ali para tentar garantir
isso e com essa nova possibilidade eles
deram eles disseram lá que eles tiveram
100% de scord que eh a api tava
retornando a estrutura passada Então
acho que isso facilita muito aplicações
ali do
eh da da api da Open nessa linha de
transformar dados desestruturados em um
output estruturado isso ajuda muito ali
na hora de construir coisas muito muito
e aí acho que o último pedente de giro
de notícias aqui na verdade nem de
Notícias é só um update que a ai do meu
riban dos meus rbans né
Eh continua funcionando aqui no Brasil
esqueceram esqueceram a Flag ligada
esqueceram a Flag ligada assim eu
continuo não usando para muita coisa mas
a coisa mais legal que eu que eu fiz na
verdade foi
com com o o Lucas testando também foi
contar a quantidade de fund que eu tinha
na minha prateleira eh vocês não estão
vendo aqui mas o plano de fundo do Artur
é a prateleira dele de funkos e tem
muitos funkos de fato é e até eu eu não
parei para contar e realmente tem uns
quase uns 40 aqui 30 e poucos e ele
falou cara tem aproximadamente 34 não
sei o qu depois eu contei realmente
Então assim tá aí vou trazendo o seu
grande uso he se eu tiver mais usos
exato grande uso parabéns
ai é isso é
[Música]
isso nesse segundo bloco A gente vai
falar da NVidia que foi pega no pulo
usando conteúdo protegido para treinar
um modelo de vídeo que eles estão
desenvolvendo internamente que o nome é
Project Cosmos e vazou uma porrada de
mensagem deack documento da empresa
então um monte tipo tá lá escancarado
para quem quiser ver eh de conversas
deles falando sobre baixar e usar vídeos
do YouTube para treinamento
eh filme da Netflix filme do Discovery
Channel e além dessas coisas também tem
uma série de datasets que eles estavam
usando ali pro treinamento que não são
liberados para usos em aplicações
comerciais que era o que eles estavam
fazendo Inclusive tem mensagens
explicitamente deles dizendo não estamos
fazendo research não vamos publicar Car
nada estão estamos de fato criando algo
aqui que vai ser um modelo comercial
eventualmente até achei interessante que
eles falam ah filmes são excelentes
formas de gerar conteúdo para jogos ali
né da gente tem modelos 3D para jogos e
tal então tavam a Nvidia tem todo um
scopo enorme né de coisas que eles atuam
então tavam dando pulão ali para
acelerar esse treinamento e o que eu
achei interessante dessa notícia além de
da Polêmica em si né E tem várias outras
polêmicas que surgiram aí nas últimas
semanas de empresas treinando modelos em
conteúdo que não deveriam e a discussão
que eu queria trazer pra gente é como
que a gente pessoas de produto e baixo
clero no geral das empresas que que a
gente deveria fazer em situações como
essa Onde existe uma aprovação da
direção então tem também lá no nos
prints ó a direção falou que pode fazer
manda manda bala aí sem problemas então
Tem alguém de cima dizendo que é para
fazer algo que é legalmente errado e
eticamente questionável no mínimo e eu
acho que com uso cada vez maior de ai
mais times e pessoas vão se deparar com
esse necessidade parecida com isso né
muitas vezes a gente nem vai est
pensando se a gente pode est usando ou
não determinado conteúdo para
treinamento Então acho que tem vários
exemplos lá de product managers dando
opiniões e tomando decisões tem a ver
com isso acho que isso vai ficar cada
vez mais comum no nosso dia a dia né
trabalhando com produtos de treinamentos
de modelos que a vai ter muitas empresas
é definitivamente e cara reportagem
cheia dos print fofoca com qualidade né
parab le dia da 404
Mia
olha com
e tampando alguns nomes cara muito bom
assim olha de parabéns não dá pr dizer
que não aconteceu né tanto que as
respostas da NVidia não era tipo não
rolou é não a gente tá aqui a gente
acredita que o nosso uso é Fair então
estão se aproveitando ali da da parte
cinza da regulação vamos dizer assim é e
aquela parada né como diria char BR Cada
escolha uma rencia é a vida né então
assim quer o charli bru do Snoop não
grande charli brau pô Chorão cara
imaginao na linha do que só tem duas
dois pontos de vista assim acho que um
tem o interno de quem é as pessoas
trabalhando lá para criar isso e o outro
que é o externo de quem vai utilizar de
fato isso sabe que é aquela coisa muitas
vezes você fala cara beleza eu vendo
meus dados mesmo eu sei que quando você
AL aceita lá os termos US para que você
tá
assinando que a sua vida vai est exposta
ali provavelmente então assim pro
usuário final o quanto o quanto é um
problema esse esse uso não sei mas eu
acho que evidentemente vai trazer mais à
tona essa questão do tipo caraca como
essas coisas estão sendo treinadas como
eh pô esses dados aqui tudo mais e acho
que é um problema para quem tá criando
principalmente né Acho que muitos
Creators no YouTube a reclamação deles é
cara não deveria está sendo treinado
coisa aqui Inclusive tem essa discussão
no chat lá da envid que é Ah eles não
tão a gente tá baixando 8 Milhões de
vídeos Eles não estão ganhando dinheiro
com os anúncios que seriam veiculados
nesse vídeo Então vamos rodar isso no
Google Cloud que a gente tá pagando pelo
menos
pelo pro esse dinheiro né aparentemente
era um di antigo que eles tinham lá de
uma outra coisa que não era isso até
então então acho que tem essa percepção
uma porcentagem pequena de usuários vai
falar não vou usar por conta disso né eh
vão ter isso vão ter que os usuários vão
querer se aprofundar mais mas a grande
parte tá querendo é
usar internamente aí amigão também tem
as ne fatores né tem isso levantar Cara
isso aqui é bem estranho a gente não
pode fazer isso aqui uma coisa era se
fosse assim cara a gente quer utilizar
isso aqui mas não dá a gente não pode
tem alguma coisa que a gente pode fazer
alguma brecha aqui na parada pra gente
poder fazer isso é eu consigo enxergar
essa situação aconteceu assim como expm
de Startup né Eu acho que você também já
deve ter passado por situações assim que
tem muitas vezes que tipo cara não tem
ali um um negócio que diga que você não
pode fazer algo mas também não tem que
diga que você necessariamente pode fazer
então muitas vezes até a sua discussão
com o time de liga ou compliance eu
gostaria de fazer isso tem como a gente
fazer tipo acho que os melhores times de
liga o que eu trabalhei inclusive eles
eram esses facilitadores assim de não de
[__] os caras tão burando a lei nem nada
mas tipo de encontrar caminhos pra gente
fazer as coisas de forma que a gente se
mantivesse lá sabe Total Então acho que
tem esse ponto e o outro quer né todo
mundo tem seus princípios e suas contas
para pagar Aí cabe de cada um cada um
vai poder dizer que é cara isso rompo
meus princípios a ponto de eu não querer
trabalhar mais aqui por conta disso e
outras pessoas que vão falar ah eu não
concordo mas tá caindo aqui eu aei não
me agride agride é Então
é eu acho que uma decisão muito acertada
até da reportagem é que eles escondem os
nomes dos funcionários mais de níveis
mais baixo né do baixo clero e eu acho
que isso é real porque cara ali o
basculo de fato ele não é ele que tá
tomando a decisão de fazer aquilo ele tá
encontrando formas de fazer mas de novo
eu penso ali um PM cara você como PM tá
pensando num jeito de operacionalizar
aquele produto né E você tem outros
times para te darem suporte em relação a
isso né se você junto com o seu time de
Liga seu time de ligao Fala aí ó Ok pode
ir lá o risco não tem risco ou o risco é
esse aí junto com outro stakeholders
vocês decidem tomar decisão cara é parte
da vida né acho muit das decisões que a
gente toma em produto no dia a dia elas
são el são arriscadas de Fato né não são
certezas e e eu acho que de novo o que
você falou né Tem coisas que V ser a a
ética ela não é ela não é binária né ela
não é tipo isso é ético ou isso não é
ético a ética ela é de cada um E aí vai
de cada pessoa avaliar se aquele negócio
tá perindo ela de de alguma forma ou não
você lá Acha que [__] cara isso aqui não
isso aqui é um crime eu não acho que
tipo necessariamente você ferir um termo
de serviço ali configura um crime né ou
mais um mau uso uma uma má prática mas
acho que o acho o clero Não não pode ser
responsabilizado nesses casos assim ele
tem que decidir se para ele faz sentido
aquilo ou não né É [__] situação difícil
quero passar não vamos ver os próximos
passos que que vai pintar aí né cara mas
que é o um um babado aí da eu queria
mais fofocas de outras empresas fazendo
isso com com tantas provas é com
detalhes assim detalhes sórdidos assim
com prints das mensagens no Slack m acho
muito legal ver comunicações
corporativas de outras empresas assim
tem um Twitter acho que a gente até
falou aqui que ele solta
e-mails é entre empresas sim
principalmente entre CEO diretores e tal
que normalmente saem de julgamentos e
tal que essas empresas estão envolvidas
e é muito legal mano ver tipo cara os
diretores da entre Apple e Google
conversando sobre contratação de
funcionários uns dos outros discussões
estratégicas assim tem um histórico do
Bill Gates que ele não conseguia baixar
não lembro se era Windows Media Player
er era algum programa do Windows
antigamente e ele cara fez um passo a
passo detalhado dizendo porque que a
experiência era uma merda e porque que
eles tinham que melhorar sabe então eu
acho super legal esse tipo de coisa Bora
pro produtos da semana
[Música]
bora então começa aí Artur qual que foi
o seu produto da última semana Cara eu
tô muito Olímpico Então tá muito
Olímpico os os produtos que eu mais mais
utilizei inclusive várias pessoas
colocaram aqui os produtos que eu mais
utilizei nos últimos dias Eh cara foi
foi a parte de dos PES do Globo Esport
de pô vai começar é é medalha aqui
medalha colar
perdeu ganhou e tals
e e a parte do mosaico do YouTube lá do
do k que que você e outras pessoas
também
mandaram cara é já puxando o meu aqui
não tem como ser outra coisa que não
seja o mosaico do YouTube na cas TV
queria aqui deixar o meu abraço e
agradecimento asley me Obrigado por
fazerem isso ser possível porque cara é
é o meu meu minha conversa ali Wesley
Miss São pessoas que que a gente conhece
aqui que trabalh no YouTube na Live mode
ali e quando teve isso a minha pergunta
foi como eu faço para adicionar mais
mosaicos aqui como eu faço para botar
todas as transmissões possíveis nisso
daqui porque para alguém apaixonado por
Esporte começou essa época de olimpíada
é maravilhosa e não ter que ficar
trocando de canal zapeando ali ou ficar
com com cara uma coisa no computador uma
coisa na TV uma coisa no celular uma
coisa no tablet é maravilhoso então [__]
mosaico do YouTube na Casé TV e eu tô
usando muito o app das Olimpíadas também
para ver o horário das coisas ele
normalmente é o que tem o o horário mais
acertado ali então para eu me planejar
que horas que eu tenho que acordar e tal
eh eu tô usando bastante o app das
Olimpíadas E aí teve uma Gente vou vou
aproveitar falar as pessoas que mandaram
e produtos olímpicos aqui né então a
Nana a Nana mandou a Casé TV Dan leira
mandou o Globo Esporte e Olimpíadas o
Bruno mandou o YouTube Então vou assumir
aqui que também ele tá assistindo
olimpíada no YouTube Então essas foram
as pessoas que estão aí no clima
Olímpico clima Time Brasil com a gente é
isso e teve alguns outros aqui além
desses do time A Marina mandou o Wi e o
nomad ela falou nessa época de usar o d
assim eu também usei o nômade aí nas
últimas semanas Olha o aplicativo tá
muito bom por sinal
eh o andrezão mandou um jogo de
tabuleiro segunda vez que eue manda um
jogo ele tá com tempo para jogar o
potion explosion o Glau mandou do
Bradesco Saúde falou que o rebolso do do
tá funcionando muito bem O Lucas mandou
mandou da Celina do dos lá e tal falou
que o experiência tá bem legal também é
e você pulou que o Mateus que falou
mandou a Nord VPN PR gente mas o Mateus
ele npn eu estava com ele usando isso
porque era PR gente ver c t é isso é
isso inclusive um abraço aqui bem grande
pro Mateus Pra Silvinha que
recepcionaram a gente e pra Bela também
que tá para nascer aí vai nascer um
pouco antes da e elas já foram no cinema
juntas já vão ser amiguinhas aí quando
nascerem são passas de barriga Pois
é isso continue mandando pra gente toda
semana seus produtos da semana essa
semana ainda tem olimpíada Então vai ter
muito YouTube Casé TV mosaico Globo
espor por aí e vamos ver se vem um uns
Ouros aí né cara umas medalhas vai vir e
que a gente
e que os juízes roubem um pouquinho pro
nosso lado também né porque [__] a
gente só tá levando velho prova com juiz
é muito dura mano eu eu sinto todas as
pessoas estão experienciando o que a
galera que curte skate já e antes do
skate ser o esporte olímpico já
experienciavam há muito tempo que é para
você ganhar de um americano brother num
Esporte que tem juiz você tem que ser
três vezes melhor do que o americano
então anos aí vendo Luan Oliveira contra
Nadia hillston uma grande batalha do
skate que a gente perdeu várias foram
roubadas ali mas vai vir vai vir mais
medalha é
[Música]
isso então é isso aí mais um episódio
não esqueçam de deixar suas cinco
estrelas aqui de adicionar na sua
playlist compartilhar com a galera
seguir a gente nas redes sociais tanto
no Instagram quanto no Twitter no
Linkedin @ @arena @art close comk
@x e é isso a gente se esbarra aí a
qualquer momento é ô comentam lá comenta
os programas gente você não dá só like
não não dá só cinco estrelinha deixa um
comentário a gente quer saber que que
vocês estão gostando o que que vocês
querem ver mais sugestões Então tem um
monte de lugar para comentar tem
Instagram tem LinkedIn tem Spotify tem
YouTube tem substack caixa para comentar
não falta na internet então comenta lá
manda pra gente e é isso semana que vem
eu quero mais comentários a gente vai
ler o comentário de a gente vai ler os
comentários da semana é isso então até a
semana que vem até a semana que vem meu
caro valeu